hello everyone in this video I am going
to address the important issue of age
restrictions or limits that are
sometimes present in various kinds of
academic jobs in India because my own
experience is with the iits primarily
I'm going to focus on that but I believe
that it is going to be applicable to a
lot of other institutes also
this video is primarily targeted of
course to the PhD students for whom it
will be immediately relevant but my hope
is that for those students among the
senior undergraduates or the Master's
level who are planning for a career in
Academia after first going through a PhD
program they will also find this video
really useful to plan out everything
now the situation in this issue is such
that it is not really possible for me to
present any solution up front rather My
Hope Is that I will discuss a few
important things which will help you to
really understand the various issues at
hand and then plan everything
so what is the issue here
so in the various iits if you look at
the advertisement for faculty positions
at the assistant professor level you
will find that it is written that they
seek candidates who are preferably less
than 35 years old
this is for the general category
students or general category candidates
for the other category candidates there
is some age relaxation
so why is this an issue
what is the problem behind it now for
those of you who are quite young maybe
in your early 20s or so you may not
realize this upfront that is why let me
set out the timeline for you so
basically in India
we have students who get into the
various engineering and science programs
basically the undergraduate programs
around age 17 18 19 around that much of
course if you are dropping for your
preparation of the entrance examinations
you may be a little bit older
nevertheless let's say that we are
working with that age 17 18 19. so by
the time you finish your undergraduate
you are around
21 to 23 years old
and then maybe you go for a job uh or
even if you finish you join a master's
program immediately
you end up finishing your Masters by the
time you are 24 to 26 years old
all right next it is usually seen that
people want to go for some kind of job
after Masters so maybe you spend a
couple of years in a job and then if you
come back to do a PhD after that you're
already something like 27 28 years old
usually phds uh
in the iits they take something between
four to five years sometimes a little
bit more than that also uh so by the
time you finish your PhD you are already
something like 31 32 years old
if you have not done a job and you have
done one after another your
undergraduate your Masters and your PhD
then maybe a little bit less something
like 30 years old
so
the next step is to go for some kind of
a postdoc because the iit's preferably
want candidates who have some kind of a
postdoctoral experience
so you go for a postdoc uh maybe abroad
maybe in India and then
uh
as you can see already the timeline is
becoming a little bit tight if by the
time you're you have finished your PhD
you are already 32 years old or 33 years
old
okay so uh two years time you may think
at this point is quite a lot but believe
me when you're actually in a postdoc
program which is a little bit more
challenging than PhD certainly
intellectually and you have to go
through the application procedures for
the faculty positions two years goes by
in a blink
so this is the issue at hand okay so you
can already see that if you actually go
for a little bit of a job uh for a
couple of years it becomes very very
tight so what is the overall problem
associated with this thing of course
that there is some kind of a time
pressure
but beyond that if you think about the
woman candidates then it is a very very
serious problem again if you are quite
young now maybe in your early 20s you
may not realize this but as you grow
older you will realize that
at least in India
it is the experience of people that by
the time they are in that age group of
27 to 35 years old
they want to start a family maybe have
kids
so this becomes this age this 27 to 35
it becomes very critical age and uh like
those who have the some experience of
Parenthood or maybe they have seen
something uh their friends or someone
some close relative going through
Parenthood
you see like
bringing a baby to the world is just the
start after that there are so many
challenges so a woman
who has finished uh her PhD or is about
to finish her PhD if uh she she wants to
go through this thing it becomes
extremely extremely challenging of
course some people do it uh very very
successfully I am personally aware of
such cases but it is extremely extremely
challenging it is much much more
challenging for women candidates
compared to male candidates okay so this
35 age limit is really problematic in
some cases I know that this is relaxed
but again it is not the norm okay in
view of this issue and the problems at
hand it is natural for us to ask why
keep these limits I mean what is so
sacrosanct about this 35 age
so is it just in India that we have this
kind of an age limit or do we not or do
we have these kinds of age limits
elsewhere
so that's a very important question
let's let's try to discuss that a little
bit now in the UK United Kingdom and the
United States
discrimination on the basis of age is
considered to be illegal
just like discrimination on the basis of
gender race and other things they are
considered illegal
so you will never find at least in the
UK and the US any kind of official
stipulation mentioning the age so
preferably less than 35 years they will
never write
okay and it is actually seen that you
will find
cases where even at the entry level
assistant professor there are people who
have joined maybe at 40 plus years maybe
even higher I mean there are some
exceptional cases like that
okay so why can't we have that in India
well for uh starters one thing you have
to realize is that because there is no
kind no uh discrimination on the basis
of age or there is no stipulation on the
basis of age in the United Kingdom in
the U.S they also don't have any
retirement age
okay so this is true they don't have any
retirement age professors don't have a
retirement age
at least not officially they are
expected to detach I mean
at a certain age and everyone has a
shelf life we are all human beings but
officially there is nothing like that
but in India we do have in the iits the
retirement age officially is 65.
okay so earlier it was a little bit less
now it is 65 years old so uh there you
have it
so because there is an expiry date there
is also a starting date now this is
putting things in a very very I mean uh
very naive fashion looking at things in
a very nice fashion let us try to probe
a little bit deeper into this let us
consider the situation let's say in the
U.S because people are always interested
in the United States
anyone who has gone through the
experience of looking for faculty
positions in the United States will tell
you that forget your age just being good
enough for those faculty positions that
is the biggest challenge first of all
okay you may be worried about each and
everything but first of all be worried
about whether you are considered good
enough by the various selection
committees this is the most important
thing
but then it is kind of evading the
question regarding the age okay so one
may actually ask that okay there is no
official discrimination on the basis of
age but at the end of the day is it not
true that there also in the U.S also
maybe in the UK also the various
selection committees that are there for
selecting the assistant professors
they're after all made up of human
beings and like some kind of an
unconscious bias is bound to develop in
the minds of human beings it is after
all human nature
so what about that
well let us consider the situation
so suppose you have a candidate who is
like in his uh his or her early 30s kind
of a rising Superstar and you have
another candidate who is perhaps close
to 40. so
uh who do you think the selection
committee will go with now this is a
very dicey question actually okay so I'm
just trying to lay out the facts before
you in the situation
it is kind of dicey because it can go
either way perhaps they can think that
they are not officially discriminating
on the basis of age but they will I mean
and and this it is uh kind of
unofficially known that sometimes what
happens is that the selection committees
think on these terms that perhaps the
younger candidate the one who is in his
early 30s he'll be more energetic these
are the kinds of terms that are used in
the discussions they are more energetic
and perhaps
they will be at in a position to serve
the department if selected for a longer
amount of time compared to a candidate
who is older so the kind of output that
can be extracted from this younger
candidate as he goes through his
academic career and being part of the
department that is much higher the
probability of that is much higher so
these are the kinds of some thought
processes that people go through there
is also another Factor at play so for a
candidate who is relatively younger
maybe in his early 30s
sometimes it is said that this candidate
has not become set in his ways set in
his ways means he is quite malleable in
his thinking and perhaps if he is taken
into the department he can be
uh he or she can be mentored in the kind
of traditional systems of the department
like every department has a certain kind
of tradition a certain kind of way of
doing things maybe he or she can be
mentored on the contrary a person who is
older he or she may not be mentored or
may not be amenable to such kind of
mentorship so you see
we are kind of uh discussing things on
very ah
I would say for lack of a better word
non-concrete grounds okay these are I
mean very nebulous kinds of things okay
so and these are the kinds of arguments
which are also given forward or at least
thought about uh when ah when we come
back to India and we try to defend that
35 uh
age limit
okay so whether it is an unconscious
bias or some kind of an explicit uh
written down bias uh like preferably 35
years old you see these are the kinds of
a thought process that people go through
now
what about the flip side one may as well
argue that an older candidate
maybe who is closer to 40 and applying
for an assistant professor position
maybe he has gone through some kind of
an experience in some industry
okay and or maybe in some kind of
teaching profession or whatever maybe he
is if not anything else he has he has
just has more experience in life what
about that is that not valuable actually
this is an argument which is uh actually
put forward in some selection committees
also
okay uh
that perhaps he will be his experience
will be something valuable sometimes it
is also said that perhaps if he has been
in the postdoc stage for quite a few for
for a significant number of years
through that through that experience he
has
gained contacts with various places and
that experience that contact uh perhaps
would be very valuable to the students
when this person joins to the department
compared to somebody much younger who
has maybe just a couple of years of
postdoc experience after his or her PhD
so you see this age argument can work
both ways I mean I've gone back to the
to the US or the UK now so does it not
apply to India
well
you think about it I mean it may very
well be applicable in India also so why
have this age limit however we have to
load one very very important thing even
though there is no explicit age bias in
the UK and the United States it is true
that in their eligibility criteria it is
officially stated many a time that the
candidate must not have had more than
this many number of years of experience
beyond the PHD so
it is not a restriction on the absolute
biological age of the candidate rather
it is sometimes referred to informally
as the PHD age so if you have maybe done
your pH in a certain year then at the
time of application it should not be
that more than 10 years ago you have
done your PhD that kind of a thing is
sometimes mentioned okay and I think
that is more common globally so one may
actually argue that perhaps in India
also we can have such a thing instead of
so in the iits instead of the 35 years
age limit we could have such a thing
that we say that all right
if the candidate has if the candidates
have done uh their PHD may be you know
within the last 10 years it's fine uh we
don't care about their biological age
that is a viable solution so one
possible argument for this age
restriction of 35 years is that or
whatever it could be 36 or 34 whatever
is that you see in the absence of this
kind of an age restriction what happens
is that
people who are
really really very interested in going
for academic jobs they keep on trying
for this
okay so year after year they keep on
trying for this uh so always with the
hope that maybe the next year it will
happen maybe the next day it will happen
so if we if we restrict this kind of a
thing at 35
I don't know maybe it is a good thing
that we kind of uh explicitly say that
I mean after this
I mean you do not waste your time
but
I mean I myself can give another five
arguments to counter this also I do not
know
and please note that if we compare the
Indian situation uh or the faculty
application situation in the iits and
the faculty application situation in the
United States for example especially the
United States
the United States is much much more
competitive it is it's very very Fierce
very Cutthroat uh and the candidates who
are now applying there
maybe they are better than many of the
professors who are already there and
even then the competition is such
Cutthroat that they are still not
getting the jobs there
okay so in the recent years people who
have gotten jobs in the United States in
the in the elite universities in the in
the big name universities uh
you can more or less rest assured that
they have done really something special
uh
in their PHD and their postdoc up
of course there are a few other factors
okay some non-academic factors are also
at Place sometimes so we also also have
to remember those things uh sometimes
things like context do matter all right
so these are the big points uh now
finally uh if you ask me
what is my personal opinion what do I
think whether this 35 years age should
be there or not this restriction should
be there or not
ah see if I were a candidate and I was a
candidate uh
back in that age and that that ancient
time of 2015 2016. uh
I
see I look at it this way that
if there is a possibility of some kind
of an unconscious bias
okay and it is always there after all as
I said it's human beings sitting in the
selection committee I would rather have
some kind of a preference being
explicitly stated in the rules and
regulations okay rather than having to
fight uh like put up some kind of an
implicit fight against something which
is not stated but which people anyway
kind of think about uh
behind my back okay so in that way I
have a slight preference for this system
even though it sounds a little bit cruel
uh on paper it's written as 35 years but
maybe
who knows uh maybe someone more
experienced than me can can can suggest
something better but I think if we can
have something like this many years
Beyond PhD I think that would be some
kind of a more balanced system
but again it is Up For Debate so there
you have it so this is the overall
situation uh now that you are probably a
little bit more aware of the overall
thing how it is uh what what are the
said and the unsaid things maybe you can
plan your career a little bit better
that is my hope uh and all the best to
you thank you